لكل بلد طقوس خاصه في رمضان ففي العراق
مثلا بعد الافطار يخرج صغار الى الاحياء
البغداديه وينشدون الانشوده التراثيه
البغداديه
زينب بالمشاط وفينا بهذه القصه الجميله
[موسيقى]
بعد مدفع الافطار وتناول الفطور يستعد
صغار بزينهم البغدادي لممارسه الماجينه
اني منكم الفطور
البس الدشداشه والعبايه والبس العرق شينه
ونطلع انا والجهال نلعب لعبه ماجينا
[موسيقى]
ماجينا يا ماجينا حليتيس وانطينا رب
العالمين ينطيكم وتنطونا كل ما جينا انها
انشوده من التراث العراقي ينشدها ابناء
الازقه البغداديه القديمه في رمضان وبعد
الافطار مباشره لهذه الانشوده حكايه
مرتبطه بتاريخ بغداد وهويه ابنائها
الاصلاء
[موسيقى]
يطوف الصغار على البيوت منشدين الماجينا
فيخرج الكبار لهم بصواني الحلويات
والاطعمه الطيبه واحيانا بالمال ما جئنا
ما جينا هي تراث من ابانا واجدادنا احنا
نتمسك به هذا وهذا الشيء حلو فرحه للاطفال
ونفس الوقت يعني البيوت تتالف بيناتهم كل
سنه جهال يجون من بعد الفطور يجون يدقون
الباب يعني يقومون ما جينا يا ما جينا
فاحنا ايش عندنا مثل حلويات اما حلويات
اما فلوس
ظل هذا الحي محافظا على احياء تقليد
الماجينه الذي بقي اسمه مجهول المعنى
فالبعض يقول انه اسم لسيده كانت تكرم
الصغار في شهر رمضان وروايات اخرى تذكر ان
الكلمه تعني لولا كما جئنا اي لولا الشهر
الفضيل وتذكر بعض القصص ان الكلمه تعود
للغه الاورديه ومؤلفه من مقطعين وتعني
التصالح والغفران زينب المشاط مساء
العربيه بغداد